مساء الخير انا ميسون نويهد اقدم لكم
اخبار الساعه اللعناوين
يمكن للعربيه التصعيد لا يخدم
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين وزيارتي تستهدف
خفض التوتر
ورام الله تعتبرها اجراءات عقاريه جماعيه
تقارير امريكيه تؤكد ان اسرائيل استهدفت
مجمعا دفاعيا في اصفهان بايران بطائرات
مسيره
وتصاعد الدعوات لامداد كيف بالمقاتلات
والدفاع الاوكرانيه تؤكد ان اجتماع النيه
المقبل سيناقش الطلب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا قبل الدخول بملفات
اخبار الساعه سنتوقف مع الاخبار العاجله
حيث افادت مصادر عراقيه بسماع دوي
انفجارات على الشريط الحدوديه العراقيه
السوريه غربه محافظه الانبار في مدينه
القائم وافادت مصادر بان الانفجارات طالت
سيارات تابعه لمليشيات عراقيه مدعومه من
ايران كما يذكر ان هذه المنطقه شهدت عده
استهدافات خلال السنوات الماضيه
وهذه اخبار عاجله ايضا مصادر للعربيه 25
شاحنه عبرت من العراق الى سوريا من منفذ
توسيطر عليه ميليشيا حزب الله للمزيد حول
هذا الموضوع ينضم اليه من اربيل مراسل
العربيه احمد الحمداني احمد اهلا بك معنا
ماذا لدينا من تفاصيل حول سماع دوي هذه
الانفجارات في القائم
طبعا ميسون بدايه المعبر الذي عبرت منه
الشاحنات هو معبر يتبع
لفصيل مسلح عراقي ويقع لا يبعد كثيرا عن
المعبر الرسمي معبر القائم
وكاد يكون عن بضعه مياه الامطار عنه وهو
الذي يستخدم لحبور الشاحنات الى
الاراضي السوريه
من الشاحنات همم حتى همم بدا سيل من
الصواريخ تهاجم هذه الشاحنات بالفعل طبعا
انفجارات عنيفه هزت مدينه القائمه
الحدوديه تحدث عن مدينه القاميه تماما على
الحدود العراق
السوريه بمعنى ان المعبر من ضمن مدينه
القائم الحدوديه بالتالفه ان سكان القائد
قد هزت منازلهم تلك الانفجارات وقد سمعت
بوضوح وانها كانت في الاراضي سوريا ما ان
عبرت الى منطقه البوكمال دخلت الاراضي
السوريه حتى حتى ااه هجمت بص- بصواريخ
طائرات مسيره وطبعا كانت مصادر تفيد بان
كان هناك تحليق لطيران مسير يراقب المنطقه
منذ منذ ظهيره اليوم بالثالثه كان يتوقع
ان تكون هناك ضربه او هجوم في مكان ما
بحسب سكان مدينه القاهره
التحالف هو من قصف هذه الشاحنات
حتى الان لا يوجد اي بيان رسمي من التحالف
الدولي نحتاج الى بيان رسمي من البنك
والعقل تقدير التي تقود التحالف الدولي
في في تبنيها عشان هذه الضربات ولكن هذه
ليست المره الاولى التي يستهدف في نفس
المنطقه ونفس المكان ونفس
الاشباح لان هذه المنطقه مراقبه همم من
طيران مسير همم تعذر صهاريج وتعبر همم
شاحنات محمله
بشحنات غير معروف طبعا
هل طيران التحالف تبنى هذا القصف فان
اسرائيل تبنت هذا القصف في المرات السابقه
المره السابقه
طبعا كانت اسرائيل تحدثت عن هذا القسم وان
قصفت طبعا تسريبات
من قصفت الشاحنه رقم ثمانيه او كذا من هذا
القبيل بالتالي فكان هناك تفصيلات من من
اعلام اسرائيل بانهم بان اسرائيل هي قامت
بقصف تركيا
على ما يبدو على ما يبدو المراقبين الناس
تقع ضمن الضربات الاسرائيليه على الاضاف
قدرات ايرانيه في داخل سوريا مطار دمشق
ومناطق دمشق وايضا بكمال والمقرات
الايرانيه الموجوده في تلك المنطقه
حول هذه الانفجارات وحول رتل الشاحنات
التي عبر من القائم الى البوكمال السوريه
شكرا لك من اربيل مراسل العربيه احمد
الحمداني
[موسيقى]
وهنبدا مع ملفات اخبار الساعه في جوله
الرابعه الى الشرق الاوسط التي ستشمل مصر
اسرائيل الضفه الغربيه بدا وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينكين زياره رسميه الى
القاهره لمده يومين حيث يلتقي الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي ونظيره سامح
شكري ومسؤولين اخرين لكن قال ان الزياره
تهدف لتعزيز الامن الاقليمي في المنطقه
والعالم وفي مقابلاته مع العربيه اكد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انطوني بلينكن ان ايران
رفضت المعروضه بشان العوده للاتفاق النووي
كما تحدث عن علاقته واشنطن مع السعوديه
وقال ان العلاقه الثابته وتتطور وذات
اهميه ومستمره وموضوع اما بخصوص الشان
الذي يمكن على ان ليبيا تحتاج الى حكومه
واضحه وشرعيه تمثل الشعب الليبيا لكنها
ايضا الى ان اي عمليه عسكريه في سوريا ست
وشتت جهود مواجهه داعش مؤكدا المواصلات
الاداره الامريكيه دعم القوات العراقيه في
مواجه كده عاش
لينكن قال في مقابلاته الخاصه مع العربيه
انه سيتحدث مع الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والسلطه الفلسطينيه لخفض التصعيد وداع
كافه الاطراف الى التحلي بالهدوء
ما يهم هو التحلي بالهدوء وفي الايام
القادمه سنتحدث الى الحكومه الاسرائيليه
والسلطات الفلسطينيه
مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه لنبدا مع
الملف الايراني ابرز ما جاء في هذه
المقابله عن علاقه مع ايران وايضا ابرز
المواقف من من قبل الولايات المتحده اتجاه
ايران
اهلا بك ميسون اعتقد بان الاداره
الامريكيه تؤكد عبر وزير الخارجيه من هل
لم تسمح لايران بامتلاك سلاح نووي يا ترى
بان الفرصه بالعوده للاتفاق النووي في
فيينا لم تعد قائمه يا ترى بان الاحداث
التي تجري الان في ايران من اعتقالات
واعدامات ضد المتظاهرين تعقد الصوره بشكل
كبير وترى بان ايران غير جده رغم ذلك يا
تحتفظ بالخيار الدبلوماسي لكن يبدو بانه
غير موجود حاليا ولم يعد في اولويات
الاداره عدا عن ذلك اعتقد بانه عندما
حاولت ان اعرف منه ما هو الخيارات الاخرى
بالنسبه للولايات المتحده لا تفضل الخيار
العسكري وتريد من ايران من امتلاك قنبله
نوويه همم قالب يمكن للعربيه بانه بالفعل
همم الاداره لديها كل الخيارات على
الطاوله بما فيه الخيار العسكري لكن على
كل الاحوال اعتقد بانه هذه الاداره ملتزم
على الاقل حاليا بالتشاور مع حلفاء الاو
في المحله فيها في الخليج وفي المنطقه
بانه على ايران ان تكف عن الاستفزازات
التي نراها من هنا تاتي هذه المناورات
العسكريه التي تجريها الولايات المتحده مع
اسرائيل ودول الاخرى لصد الهجمات
الايرانيه بدعم وكلائها في المنطقه وموضوع
الثابت هو موضوع الدعم المتظاهرين كما
ذكرت حاولت ان اعرف منه اكثر هل الولايات
المتحده تحاول تغيير النظام اذا اردت
بطريقه ما طبعا قال بان هذا الامر الداخلي
شان داخلي والولايات المتحده تدعم
المتظاهرين كانت توفر لهم الاساليب التي
يمكن من خلالها الاتصال مع العالم ايضا
وضعت عقوبات على منتهيه همم حقوق الانسان
في ايران نعم وعلى القضاء الذين يصدرون
همم احكام بالاعدام وقامت بطرد ايران من
مجلس حقوق المراه كما تعرفين في الامم
المتحده وبالنسبه لتصعيد الحاصل اليوم بين
الفلسطينيين واسرائيل هو قال بانه من ابرز
اهدافه هو تخفيف هذا التصعيد ماذا في
تفاصيل ايضا حول هذا الموضوع
طبعا مهمه صعبه ستواجه بلينكين عندما نذهب
غدا الى القدس وبعد له لقاء مع الرئيس او
الفلسطيني في رام الله كان الهدف من هذه
الزياره بالدرجه الاولى وبالفعل التهدئه
وعدم التصعيد قبل احداث جنين وقبل احداث
احداث النبي يعقوب لكن الاداره كانت تريد
من نتنياهو ان يكون هناك التزام بعدم
اللجوء الى خطوات يمكن ان تقود حلقه
دولتين مثل توسيع المستوطنات الى غيره لكن
الان هناك الكثير الذي سيتحدث عنه الوزير
وخصوصا حول ما نرى من عقوبات جماعيه
تتخذها اسرائيل ضد الفلسطينيين بحجم
البيوت وغيرها وهي طبعا كما تعرفين كلها
مناف يعني القانون الدولي وفي نفس الوقت
يريد التزام من الفلسطينيين ربما بعوده
التنسيق الامني وبعدم اللجوء للمحاف
الدوليه مثل المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
لكنه طبعا سيكشف اللي انا عن تفاصيل اكثر
وسنساله اسئله اكثر خلال هذه الجوله غدا
سيكون له لقاء مع وزير الخارجيه المصري
سامح شكري وطبعا انا سنحاول الاصل وايضا
سؤال عن العلاقات المصريه وعن الوضع
المتوتر بين اسرائيل وبين الفلسطينيين
ودائما ناديه سنكون معكي لتطلعين على ابرز
المواقف وابرز هذه اللقاءات التي ستجري في
خلال هذه الزياره شكرا لك ناديه بلبيسي
مفردات العربيه كنت معي من القاهره
فلسطين في القدس خلال اليومين الماضيين
وفق مجلس الوزراء المصغر في اسرائيل على
اجراءات تسهل على الاسرائيليين الحمله
السلاح هذه الخطوات تشمل اجراءات ضد
منفذين عمليات وعائلاتهم وتعزيز الاستططان
ونطاق حمل الاسلحه كما اعلنت الحكومه
الاسرائيليه التكليفه وزير الداخليه
باعداد قانونا لحرمان منفذي الهجمات
وداعمهم من الجنسيه وتعمل الحكومه
الاسرائيليه على مشروعي القانون الاول
للفصل داعمين الهجمات من وظائف فورا دون
تحقيق والثاني سيسمح بترحيل الداعمين
الهاشميه الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه
اكاديميه مول
في المقابله داله الخارجيه الفلسطينيه
قرارات الحكومه الاسرائيليه ضد
الفلسطينيين التي اعتبرتها عقوبه جماعيه
وتحرض على المزيد من العنف ومن شانها ان
تصب الزيت على النار وان تفاقم الوضع كما
دعت الخارجيه الفلسطينيه الحكومه
الاسرائيليه الى العمل على احياء المسار
السياسي بين الجانبين وتجنب التصعيد
هذا وقالت وكاله الانباء الفلسطينيه ان
شابا فلسطينيا قتل برصاصه مستوطن اسرائيلي
شرق بلده القياف الضفه الغربيه بحسب مصادر
امنيه فان كرم علي سلمان البالغ 18 عاما
من بلده قوسين غرب نابلس قتل برصاص
ومستوطن قربه مستوطنه
هذا وداع وزير الخارجيه الروسيه سرج
الابراج نظيره الفلسطيني رياض المالكي
والاسرائيلي كوهين الى منع اي اعمال تؤدي
الى تصعيد في المنطقه وذكرت وكاله سبوتنيك
الروسيه ان دعوه الابراج جاءت خلال
اتصالين منفصلين مع نظريه الفلسطيني
والاسرائيلي ووافق بيان للخارجيه فان
لابروفاكد على الحاجه الملححه الى تجديد
الجهود لاعاده المفاوضات بين الجانبين
من تل ابيب معي دبلوماسيه السابق اسحاق
لبنون سيد اسحاق على الرغم من المحاولات
للتهدئه ولكن الخطوات التي تاخذها اسرائيل
هي تصعيديه صاحب جنسيه ترحيل ااه هذه
المنفذين وداعمهم ما هو سقف هذا التصعيد
لا احد يعرف ما هو ساكن في عدا الحكومه
بنفسها ولكن هي تتزوج بهذا الموضوع بعد
الجريمه التي حصلت وانا اظن انه اسرائيل
او الشعب الفلسطيني او المجتمع الاسرائيلي
ليساعته ان يمر بذلك بدون ان يعطي جواب
لكي نصل الى وضع يكون يعني ثابت اكثر
بيننا وبيننا الفلسطيني ولذلك نحن نطلب
ايضا من السلطه الفلسطينيه ان تتدخل ولكن
للاسف الشديد السلطه الفلسطينيه لا تعمل
شيء هي وقفت التنسيق الامني بيننا وبينهم
وبالاضافه الى ذلك هي لا تريد ان تستنكر
هذا الهجوم الوحشي على سبع اشخاص في
الكنيس ليله السبت همم ولذلك
السلاح بالنسبه للاسرائيليين همم لا يفاقم
الوضع اكثر
لا بالعكس يعني الوضع هو ان رحنا ما راينا
في الاشهر القاضي
السابقه انه بعض الاشخاص من المدايين او
من
[موسيقى]
طاقم المساعده
للجواحه والكتله والاخره عندما كان لهم
اسلحه هم وقفوا الهجوم ولذلك الحكومه قالت
اذا في كان هنالك اسرائيليين يريدون ان
يحملوا سلاح هذا هو الوقت ولكن فقط على
الدفاع عن النفس مش اكثر من ذلك
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه سي يتجه الى
القدس هل برايك هناك همم مجال لاي مبادره
جديده لتخفيف هذا الاحتقال وهذا التصعيد
سيكون في اسرائيل وايضا في السلطه
الفلسطينيه ولذلك انا مقتنع ان القضيه
الفلسطينيه او العلاقات بيننا وبين السلطه
او الوضع على الارض وسيكون من المحادثات
المباشره بيننا وبين ما عدا ما كان يعني
مع مصر ودول المصري والاسرائيلي في الشرق
الاوسط بما في ذلك السعوديه والكفاح تضلها
انا اظن ان القضيه الفلسطينيه عامكن ستكون
احد المواضيع الاساسيه بيننا وبينه عندما
اوصاف الامريكي يريد ان ناخذ
الخطوات المتبادله الفلسطينيه
والنقطه الثانيه هو يريد ان لا احد من
الطرفين يا مصر
بالوجهه الامريكيه بما يسمى في الحل
للدولتان دوله فلسطينيه ودوله اسرائيليه
همم يعيشان جانبا الى جنب هذا هو الاتجاه
همم الشامل للسيد لا يمكن في اسرائيل
معه لقاء مع العربيه وكان لديه ايضا مواقف
من موضوع ايران دعنا نستمع لما قاله من ثم
نتابع معك هذا الموضوع حيث اكد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلانكن في
لقائه الخاص مع العربيه بان الولايات
المتحده الان تركز على جانب قمع المظاهرات
من قبل النظام الايراني كما شدد على وجهه
نظر الرئيس في ايجاد حلل ديبلوماسي فيما
يخص البرنامج النووي الايراني
يتجه نحو الاحداث العديده مثل قمع
المظاهرات في ايران النساء يدافعنا عن
حقوقهم ويت قمعوهن بعنف من قبل النظام وفي
نفس الوقت نرى ايران تدعم روسيا في حربها
ضد اوكرانيا وتقدم لها المسيرات والاسلحه
الاخرى ونرى ايضا ان الدبلوماسيه هي الحل
الوحيد لبرنامج ايران النوويه والرئيس
بايدن كان واضحا ان كل الحلول مطروحه لمنع
ايران من الحصول على اسلحه النوويه
هل تشعرون بان هناك اي تغيير بلهجه
الولايات المتحده اتجاه ايران وخاصه موضوع
الملف النووي وما يجري ايضا من احتياجات
وقنع هذا داخل ايران
بخصوص الاحتجاجات الولايات المتحده تعب
ذلك بالموقف الايراني والروسي في اوكاينا
لان الولايات المتحده هي متدخله جدا في
اوكاينا ولا على رضا ما يكون بين موسكو
بين طهران بهذا الخصوص لانه ااا
ايران
روسيا
باسلحه وهذا همم الولايات المتحده نفسها
راضيه بذلك بخصوص همم الموقف الامريكي
بشان النووي الايراني انا اظن ان الموقف
الامريكي هو واضح جدا بانه الاتفاق الذي
وصل اليه في سنه 2015
الجديد ما فيش يعني اي همم اتفاق ولذلك
انا اظن البنات المتحدات تريد بالغاء من
كل ذلك ان تصل بصوره دبلوماسيه ولكن انا
لا هذا ذلك في الافق لانه الاتجاه
الايراني هو مختلف الايراني
هو مختلف شكرا لك من تل ابيب بدي كلاسيك
السابق
[موسيقى]
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه في مقابله مع
العربيه
مع الحكومه العراقيه لدعم الشراكه بين
البلدين
هناك امر مهم بشان العلاقه مع العراق منها
ان تتصدى الحكومه العراقيه لداعش ويكون
لديها القدره على ذلك اتخذنا اجراءات لدعم
العراق على مواجهه داعش ولدينا شراكه
واسعه نطاق معها العراق يعمل بشكل جديد
من بغداد ينضم الى دكتور حسين علاوي
مستشار رئيس الوزراء العراقي الدكتور
علاوي اهلا بكم معنا كيف تصف هذه الاجابات
حول العراق من قبل وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه وهذه التصريحات الايجابيه حقيقه
اتجاه العراق وعلاقتهم معهم
مساء الخير عليكم
السيد وزير الخارجيه الامريكي عندما يتحدث
عن العلاقات العراقيه الامريكيه يتحدث
بصوره واضحه جدا يتحدث في واقعيه ويتحدث
ذلك عن همم الذي يراه من قبل الحكومه
السيد محمد الشاعر السوداني رئيس الوزراء
العراق الذي يدير هذه العلاقات وهي جزء
بالمنظومه السياسه الخارجيه العراقيه كذلك
في هذا المسار وبالتالي
العلاقات العراقيه الامريكيه تسير نحو
مسار ممتاز سواء من حيث التطبيق اتفاقيه
الاطار الاستراتيجي سواء من حيث كذلك
بالمقابل التعاون المشترك الزياره
المرتقبه للوفد العراقي الوزاره الذي
سيزور همم الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وكذلك بالمقابل الحرب على همم فلول
التنظيم الارهابي داعش التي هي تشارك على
نهايتها لاننا همم نرى ان القوات العراقيه
همم تتقدم باتجاهات متعدده همم وتنتقل الى
بناء القدرات وتنتقل كذلك الى التدريب
والم في التمارين المشتركه كانت مع همم
دول مثل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والدول التحالف الدولي او كذلك بالمقابل
مع دول المنطقه التي جرت مؤخرا مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وقد تكون مع دول عربيه
اخرى وهذا بالتالي ملاحظه لان نمر بمرحله
ما بعد الانتصار على التنظيم الارهابي
داعش وهي مرحله بناء السلام وهذا بالتالي
جل هذا الاتجاه همم يمثله الان المنهاج
الوزاري لحكومه السيد محمد
السودانيه
الفساد هو ايضا من ابرز الاولويات التي
دائما تطالب فيها الولايات المتحده العراق
هل العراق على المسار السليم بهذا الموضوع
هذا سؤال مهم جدا حقيقه السيد رئيس وزراء
استاذ محمد الشاعر السوداني منذ الايام
الخمسه الاولى لدارته للحكومه العراقيه
الجديده عمل على مكافحه الفساد بمواجهه
صفقه القرن الفاسده التي كانت تذهب الى
سرقه اموال عراقيه
وتحاول ان تهربها الى خارج العراق وذهب
البعض منها وكذلك البعض منها بقى في
العراق وبالتالي هي اوقفت هذه الجريمه
الكبرى وكذلك بالمقابل جريمه تهريب
المشتقات النفطيه قد وقف ضدها وكذلك اعطت
دور كبير جدا لمؤسسه دور هيئه النزاهه همم
في اداره ومكافحه الفساد وكذلك اعطاء دور
كذلك لوزاره الداخليه باعتباره مؤسسه
قانون في عمليه همم تنفيذ الاوامر
القضائيه التي تصدر بعد التحقيقات او كذلك
همم من قبل هيئه النزاهه باتجاه الفاسدين
او الشخصيات التي شار اليها بالفساد وكذلك
المسار الثالث وهو عمليه تحول الرقمي الان
التي تجري في الموازنه الاتحاديه في
التعاملات كذلك الماليه وكذلك في همم
سياسه البنك المركزي في عمليه همم صرف
الدينار مقابل الدولار العراقي ادي العدد
دولار الامريكي الدكتور حسين علاوي مستشار
رئيس الوزراء العراقي شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
والمشاهدين ان نعود لنتابع التطورات
الحاصله في التفجيرات في وكمال السوريه
حيث المرصد الان السوري اكد بانه هناك
تدمير لست شاحنات تبريد في البوكمال جراء
غراض جويه وطبعا كان مراسلنا اكد لنا قبل
قليل سماع دوي انفجارات على شريط الحدودي
العراقيه السوريه غير بمحافظات الانبار
بمدينه القائمه همم رامي عبد الرحمن مدير
المرصد السوري ينضم الينا الان ليطلعنا
على ابرز التفاصيل رامي ماذا لدينا من
تفاصيل تفضل
شاحنات بعد دخولها الاراضي السوريه من قبل
الطائرات مسيره مجهوله اذا ما كانت
اسرائيليه كانت التحالف الدولي طبعا بعد
الاستاد حصلت انفجارات في تلك المنطقه مما
يدل بان هذه الشاحنات كانت تحمل الاسلحه
او ذخيره ولم تكن تحمل خضار وفواكه ولحومه
كان يدعي الايرانيين بانهم يقولون من
الاراضي العراقيه طبعا اليوم استضافه هذه
الشاحنات والتسبب الاستهداف بسقوط جرحه
وقتلها بشكل قطعيه سيارات الاسعاف صارت
الى تلك المنطقه من البوكمال ونقلت الجرحى
والقتلى الى مشاكل خاصه بمليشيات ايران
والسيارات والشاحنات هي التابعه للحرس
الثوري الايراني او دائما يقول لي انا
ميليشيات ايران التي تسيطر على تلك
المنطقه وقبل يومين ايضا كان هناك شاحنات
دخلت من العراق افرغت حمولتها في مدينه
الميادين كانت تحمل الاسلحه ومن ثم عادت
اتراجها باتجاه الاراضي العراقيه وكان
يقودها عناصر من حزب الله اللبناني هذه
الذين لهم مستودفوا الذين قتلوا حقيقه لا
من حط اللحظه لا نعلم هويتهم اذا ما كان
عراقيين لبنانيين سوريين عاملين على
الايرانيين ولكن بشكل مؤكد الشاحنات
التابعه للايرانيين او للرشاد ايران داخل
الاراضي السوريه
يؤكد بين الشاح طيب تم قصفها في البوكمال
تحمل اسلحه وعددها ست شاحنات
سنتابع الان مشاهدينا من ايران تحديدا من
ملف استهداف مواقع عسكريه ايرانيه بمسيرات
في محافظه اصفهان حيث قال صحيفه نيوز
تايمز ان هذه المسيارات التي يعتقد انها
انطلقت من داخل ايران في ما نقلت صحيفه
بور ستريت جورنال ان هجمات اصفهان بالامس
نفذتها اسرائيل واستهدفت مجمع الدفاعيا
وهي اول عمليه اسرائيليه داخل ايران في
فتره نتنياهو الجديده هذا واتهمت وسائل
الاعلام تابعه للحرس الثوري الايراني
اسرائيل بالوقوف في خلفه هجوم اصفهان
وهددت وسائل الاعلام تابعه لحركه ثوري
اسرائيل باستهداف في مصالحها بالمسيرات
اليوم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الانتخابات في تونس على نسبه المشاركه في
الدوره الثانيه للانتخابات 11.3%
[موسيقى]
القسطره القلبيه العلاجيه
وجراحات القلب على مداري 24 ساعه
بمستشفيات المواساه
المواساه خبره تنبض بالثقه
تويتر فيسبوك انستغرام تيك توك يوتيوب
وغيرها
[موسيقى]
عالم مليء بالمعلومات
والافكار الجديده والحوارات
في كيف بنشوف العالم حولنا
وكيف بنشوف بعضنا وكيف بنشوف انفسنا في
هذا الكون الافتراضي الفسيح
[موسيقى]
بدنا نقول لكم كل ما هو عاجل من اخبار
وطارق من احداث مثير ومشتعل من تصريحات
وجدل
من الاحد الى الخميس السادسه على الشاشه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
هذه اللحظه اللي يبدا فيها الم يخف مش
عارف يعني راح انام طول الليل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد نتابع الان من اوكرانيا
حيث يبدو ان ميدان المعركه في الاشهر
القادمه سيشهد اشد مراحل الحرب دراوى فلا
صوت يعلو على الرصاص وسط جنود يسود ساحه
الحرب حاليا ضربات روسيا مكثفات دون اي رد
اوكرانيا فيما يبقى السؤال الذي طرحته
صحيفه جاردن البريطانيه من سيضرب اولا
واين الجانبان في الوقت الحالي بحسب
الصحيفه ينشغلان بتعزيز دفاعتهما وحشت
قوتهما استعدادا لاي هجوم المحتمل من
جبهات الحرب حيث تعمل روسيا على تقويه
قوتها مع مساعد رئيس الروسي لازم يكون من
اجل الانتاج الدبابات وصواريخ جديده
محللون
بتكليف بلا رجيم اوف للاشراف المباشر عن
العمليات الاوكرانيه تنظر باستعداد موسكو
للشنه هجوما كبير خصوصا بعد ان انتهت
المرحله الاولى من الحرب بخسائر كبيره في
الشمال وفي حركات واخرسانه في صفوف الروس
وفقا للجارديان
هو بحسب الصحيفه البريطانيه هناك ثلاث
جبهات يمكن ان تكون ساحه لهذه المعارك
الضاريه في الربيع المقبل ويمكن ان يكون
حسم اي واحده منها منعرج حاسما لهذه الحرب
جبهه الشرق ونتحدث هنا عن لجانس دونيت
التي كانت مسرحا لاشد المعارف في الاشهر
القليله الماضيه هي اكثر الاماكن احتماليه
لشنها هجمات الكبرى من خلال جنابين في
الربيع جبهه الجنوب ايضا هي الجبهه الاهم
بالنسبه للطرفين الاخراني والروسيه لماذا
لانها ستقررون نتيجه الحرب برمتها سواء
جنه القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه هجومها
الاول في الشرق ام لا وتبقى جبهه الشمال
روسيا قواتها للتدريب في بيلاروسيا ولكن
يبقى هذا الامر خدمه من قبل موسكو لابعاد
القوات الاخرانيه عن الجنوب والشرق ودائما
بحسب الصحيح هنا مشاهدينا على الحدود
بالله الروسيه الاوكرانيه الوضع لا يزال
متوترا وفق ما اعلن عنه رئيس لجنه الحدود
البلار روسيه
ناتولي لابو حيث اشار الى حشد قوتك
17000 عسكري على الحدود مؤكدا انه منذ بدء
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا وصل حوالي
80 الف شخص من الاراضي الاوكرانيه الى
بيلاروسيا وان الجانب الاوكراني لا يسمح
للاوكرانيين بدخول الاراضي البلاسوسيه رغم
ان من مستعده لاستقبال
المعارف فيدونيس شرقي اوكرانيا
الروسيه السيطره على بلاه داتني في الجزء
الشرقيه
انه تصدى لهم في محيط المدينه التي يقتلها
اكثر من ثلاثه الاف نسمه
[موسيقى]
بعد الموافقه على ارسال الدبابات
لاوكرانيا على مطالبات من اوكرانيه
بالصواريخها تدمر مستودعات الروس رفقتها
ايضا ضغوط من مسؤولين في الفنتاجون
للموافقه على ارسال طائرات اف 16 الى
اوكرانيا حسب ما نقلته صحيفه بوليتكو عن
مصادر مطلعه على المناقشات الجاريه مسؤول
كبير في وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه قال
للصحيفه ان واشنطن لا تعارض الامر غير انه
لم يؤكد صدور قرار نهائيا حول الموضوع
بكلمات اخرى الحصول على مقاتلات اف 16 لم
يعد حلم مستحيله بالنسبه لي اوكرانيا ومن
الممكن ان يحصل بالفعل وترسلها واشنطن
لعده اسباب ما هي الاكياج تعول على مسانده
كبيره من الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه اضافه
لدعم مسؤولين من الجمهوريين ايضا وزاره
الدفاع الاخرانيه اعلنت ان وزراء دفاع
نيته سيناقشون تسليم اكياس مقاتلات في
اجتماعهم مقبل في المانيا في ما قال وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني اليكسي ريزني كاف في
مقابله مع قناه سي بي سي كنديه ان الوضع
العسكري في الشرق صعب لكنه تحت السيطره
بالكامل واوضح حارسنيكا في المقابله التي
اجراها ان الامر سيستغرق بعض الوقت لتلقي
الدبابات التي وعد بها الغرب ولمعرفه
كيفيه استخدامها معربا عن امله في ان تكون
جاهزه للاستخدام حلول شهر مارس
ينضم الى حذيفه عادل مراسل العربيه حذيفه
اهلا بك معنا ابرز تطورات وايضا انتظار
اوكرانيا ماذا ينتظرون من الاجتماع المقبل
للنيتو
مساء الخير ميسون بخصوص ابرز التطورات في
ساحه او في ميدان المعركه طبعا هنالك
ثلاثه محاور اساسيه ورئيسيه نتحدث عنها في
دونيسك تحديدا بيض
سكي وباخو هذه ثلاثه محاور رئيسيه في
دنيسكو وجميعها تمثل محور جبهه الكبرى
وهنا حيث القوات الروسيه تحاول عمليه حصار
القوات الاوكرانيه في مدينه باخم والسيطره
على هذه المدينه هنا تكون يعني تقوم
القوات الروسيه بعمليات عسكريه نشطه
ومحاولات للتقدم الجبهات الاخرى
تحاول فيها القوات روسيه التقدم والتحرك
ولكن حتى اللحظه بحسب بيانه هيئه اركان
المشتركه العامه الاوكرانيه عاجزه عن ذلك
وتتكبر خسائر كبيره كذلك المحور الثالث
وفي همم نجارس وهنا نتحدث عن كريم وصفات
الاوكرانيه عن العدسه تقول نعم تتقدم ببطء
ولكن هذا التقدم وشروط لان المنطقه مزروعه
بعدد كبير وهائل من الالغام هذه هو خط
النار ولكن عمليات الخاص مستمره اليوم
الكسندري رفقات تعرضت للقصف وكان هنالك
عدد من الضحايا من القتل والجرحى كذلك
مدينه خرسانه اليوم تعرضت لعمليات قصف في
مركز المدينه وادى ذلك الى سقوط عدد من
القتلى والجرحى كذلك في منطقه زبروزه في
اتجاه تحديدا قامت القوات الاوكرانيه بقصف
الجسر الذي يربط يعني هو طريق الامدادات
للقوات الروسيه في هذا الموقع قام بقصف
وقطع عن طريق الامداد في تلك المنطقه اما
بخصوص طبعا رامز
السلطات الاوكرانيه تامل في ان تستطيع ان
تحدث اختراقه في الاجتماع القادم للحصول
على اف 16 اف 16 كما قال قبل قليل همم
المتحدث والمناطق الرسمي باسم القوات
الجويه الاوكرانيه انها تستطيع ان تقوم
انها جميعا انواع الطائرات التي تمتلكها
اوكرانيا وتتحدث عن اس 24 واس 25 ومي 29
اف 16 تستطيع ان تقوم بكل هذه المهام في
وقت واحد لذلك تحاول ان تحصل عليها القوات
الاوكرانيه للقيام بعمليه هجوم مضاد
لاستعاد لاستعاده الاراضي والقيام بضربات
في عمق الخصم عمق القوات الروسيه شكرا لك
حذيفه على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل كنت
معي من كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه
[موسيقى]
وانا ذكر مشاهدينا بما اتبعناه على شاشه
العربيه منذ قليل ونعود ونتابعه الان
بخصوص اذربيجانه التي علقت العمل في
سفرتها في ايران بسبب هجوم استهدفها سابقا
وكانت ايضا في الصباح كانت اخذت الموظفين
وعائلتهم اذا هذا اخر الان تقوم اذربيجان
بتعليق العمل بالكامل في السفاره في ايران
نتابع الان من تركيا الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان الى امكانيه قبول تركيا
اندوني فنلندا الى حلف شمال الاطلسي بمعزل
عن السويد التي تشهد علاقتها توترا
متصاعدا مع تركيا
المختلفه فيما يتعلق بفندق
بالصوبه ولكن اذا لم ترتكب فنلندا نفس
الخطا
[موسيقى]
في البلاد اغلقت مراكز الاقتراع في تونس
ابوابها بنسبه مشاركه بلغت 11 فصل 3% بحسب
اخر احصائيه لهيئه الانتخابات حيث دعي نحو
سبعه ملايين و800000 ناخذ بالتصويت في
الدوره الثانيه من الانتخابات التشريعيه
ويتنافس 262 مرشحا على
131 من قعدا في البرلمان الجديد من اصل
161 اما المجلس النبي الجديد سيكون له
صلاحيات محدوده اذ لا يمكنه على سبيل
المثال عزل الرئيس ولا مساءالته اوعيه
يتمتعوا الرئيس في الاولويه في اقتراح
مشاريع القوانين كما لا يشترط الدستور
الجديد ان تنال الحكومه التي يعينها
الرئيس الثقه البرلمان اما المعارضه فلا
تزال من قسمه الى ثلاث مختلفه تتواجهات
جبهات الخلاط الوطني التي يتدعممها حسب
النهضه الحزب الدستوريه الحرب بقياده عبير
موسى وايضا الاحزاب واليساريه اذا غليان
سيا في تونس ترافقه حقيقه ازمه اقتصاديه
حاده تعاني منها البلاد فاقمها تعثر
المفاوضات الحاسمه مع صندوق النقد الدولي
للحصول على قرض بنحو ملياري دولارات مظاهر
الازمه الاقتصاديه واضحه الى حد ما ابرزها
تباطؤ النمو الى اقل من 3 وارتفاعه
البطاله الى اكثر من 15% فيما تزدادوا
مستويات الفقره التي دفعت 32 الى الهجره
بحرا نحو ايطاليا بشكل غير قانوني على 20
و22 كما يواجه التونسيون تدهورا حادا في
قدرتهم
تجاوز العشره بالمئه
نقصا في المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه على
غرار الحليب والزيت الطبخ
[موسيقى]
في اخبار الساعه بعد لحظات ما بدي حملته
الانتخابيه ترامب يؤكد على الالتزام
باستعاده البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
مباشره
منذ قليل هناك سماع ادويه سفارات انذار في
مدينه بانه الكرديه في غرب ايران نستمع
اذا مشاهدينا تبعنا صفارات الانذار التي
تدور في مدينه بنا الكرديه في غرب ايران
طبعا ليس لدينا اي تفاصيل حول سبب هذه
السفارات
وطبعا بالامس كان هناك التفجير لمجمع
صناعي في اصفهان همم بعض الصحف تحدثت بان
هذه الضربه كانت اسرائيليه ولكن ليس هناك
اي تاكيد من الجانب الاسرائيلي همم ايضا
البعض اعتبر او قال بانه سلاح الجو
الامريكي شارك بهذه الضربه ولكن كان هناك
نفسي من قبل واشنطن
اذن هذه مدينه بنا الكرديه في غرب ايران
نسمه فيها صفارات الانذار تدوي ولكن لا
تفاصيل حول سبب هذه السفرات او لماذا
اطلقت سفرات الانذار في مدينه بانا طبعا
ايران منذ فتره اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر هناك
احتجاجات كبيره في ايران وهي تتعرض ايضا
خلال السنه الماضيه للكثير من الضربات على
بعضها الصناعيه والعسكريه متابعه تطورات
حالتها
[موسيقى]
اما الان سننتقل الى الموجز الرياضي مع
اليك
[موسيقى]
شكرا ميسون اهلا بكم في نادي الاتحاد
في النهائي بهدفين من دون مقابل على ملعب
الملك فهد الدولي في الرياض
وكوره اتحاديه وحمد الله وكوره
وهدف اول
هلا هلا هلا هلا يا فنان انت كبير حد الله
شوف حمد الله كيف تحرك كيف تحرك وهنا
الدخول الحكم
سيعطي تقدير النهائي اوه اوه اوه بطاقه
حمراء العبود امام سوكوبيتش العبود في
فرصه والثاني والكوره ضاعت ضاعت ضاعت ضاعت
سيلعب الارضيه والكورنادو الى الامام
ومحاوله خطيره وبراس وفرصه والك
والكوره في
المعطن الاتحاد
واجعلني استمتع اعطني الاتحاد
اتركني لوحدي هو يضربني ويمتعني هو الحياه
والروح هو العميد احمد حجازي مع واحد
واثنين ثلاثه والاتحاد بطل بطوله سوبر
الاتحاد في العوده التاريخيه
العميد احتفاليه كبيره
اجواع كبيره في الملعب الجوع التاريخيه
وفي مصر تغلب الزمالك على ضيفه
سيف الدين الجزيره هو الاهداف الزمالك في
الدقيقه الرابعه عشر وعادل على مروان محسن
النتيجه في الدقيقه الرابعه والعشرين قبل
ان يعود الجزيره ويسجل هدف الفوز للزمالك
الذي يملك تسعه وعشره نقطه في المركز
الرابع وترجع المدرسه
[موسيقى]
سيف الدين الجزائر
مع ظهير الايمن الفرنسي معلوكوستو قادمه
من اليوم سينتد عقد اللاعب بالبالغ من
العمر 19 عاما من تشيلسي مع تشيلسي حتى
سيف عام 2030 على ان يبقى معانا للنادي
الفرنسي حتى نهايه الموسم الجديد
وداع ليفربول حمل اللقب مسابقه كاس
الاتحاد الانجليزي بخسارته امام وظيفه
برايتن بهدف لهدفين في دور الرابع من
المسابقه على ملعب امكس فبعد تمرير متقنه
من محمد صلاح ليفربول تسجيل
في الدقيقه الثلاثين وبعده بتسع دقائق
عادلا برايت عبس تنك من تسديده قويه
لتنظيم مباراه متجهه الى تعادل قبل ان
ياتي الياباني
للفوز بهدفه رائع بعد ما طلع ليفربول امام
المرمى في الوقت بعد ليفربول خرج من كاس
الرابطه ويعاني في الدوري بالمركز التاسع
تلقى ميلان خساره قاسيه بخماسيه لهدفين
انها مضيفه ساسولو الملعب صانسيرو ضمن
جوله ال 20 من الدوري الايطالي وهي المره
الاولى في تاريخ النادي تتلقى شباك ميلان
اربعه اهداف في مباراتين متتاليتين في
الدوري تلقى ميلان ثلاثه اهداف خلال 30
دقيقه في مباراه على ملعبه لاول مره منذ
عام 44 يفشل ميلان بالاقتراب من نابولي في
الصداره
فرض
التعادل على ضيفه المتصدر بهدف لكل منهما
ضمن الجوله التاسعه عشر من الدوري
الاولادي فقدم فاينارد بهدف سجله خنز في
الدقيقه الثلاثين قبل ان يتعادلات فانت عن
طريق جرش في الدقيقه الثامنه والسينما 242
نقطه في المركز الرابع
[تصفيق]
في الارجنتين فاز ليفربول
مباراه الافتتاحيه للدوري المحليه على
ملعب الفريد وتيريرا بمدينه سانتياغو
ديلستيرو الذي يشاهد احتفال الحارس الماني
بكاس العالم ورفع النسخه الطبخ الاصلي
للبطوله
فتح التسجيل الضيوف نهايه الشوط الاول
وضعف ريفر بليت النتيجه في الدقيقه 69
المركز الثاني في الترتي
بطوله استراليا المفتوحه للتنس للمره
العاشره في تاريخه بفوزه على اليوناني
ستيفانوس
بثلاث مجموعات من دون مقابل
جيكوفيتش اللقب الثاني والعشرين في غراند
هذه لانه رقم القياسيه المسجل باسم
الاسبنيه
[تصفيق]
التصنيف العالمي من الاسباني
نهايات اخبار الرياضه شكرا لمتابعتكم اعود
اليك ميسون
[موسيقى]
شكرا مشاهدينا لطيب المتابعه اخبار الساعه
انتهت اترككم في امان الله
[موسيقى]